Marla's given us permission
to provide you with her CCD.
Since she's fictional this is not
protected health information, so
you can have it and freely use it.
For this activity you should send
this CCD as an attachment, and
email it to your HealthVault
direct email address.
Before doing that,
go to your message center settings, and
make sure add incoming message
attachments as files is checked,
so the data in Marla's CCD
will be added to your record.
Once that's done, and you've imported
Marla's CCD into to your record.
Manually add the drug
Spiriva to Marla's record.
This is a drug Dr. Jones might
prescribe to help her breathe better.
Also manually add a new hemoglobin A1C,
with a level of 9.2%.
You can date them both
the date you add them.
Now go to health information and
click more actions, and
export Marla's record as a CCD.
You'll need to submit it to
get credit for this activity.